en Ukraine l'armée russe revendique à
l'instant la conquête de la ville de
soledar les autorités ukrainiennes
parlaient de combat très intense
notamment ce matin et assuré contenir
cette offensive russe la Pologne de son
côté s'est-il prête à livrer des chars
lourds des léopards 2 le Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU doit se réunir ce soir
pour parler de la guerre on retrouve
notre correspondant Gulliver crack en
route vers soumis les mercenaires russes
du groupe Wagner disent avoir pris la
ville de soledar quels sont vos toutes
dernières informations et peut-on parler
d'une défaite pour l'armée ukrainienne
ce qui change aujourd'hui c'est que ce
ne sont pas uniquement les mercenaires
du groupe Wagner qui affirment avoir
pris le contrôle de Solidar mais aussi
le ministère de la Défense russe donc
côté russe il le disent officiellement
qu'ils ont pris soleda mais côté
ukrainien la situation ne change pas
l'Ukraine n'admet pas avoir pris perdu
pardon le contrôle de cette petite ville
près de backmouth ce matin pourtant le
vice-ministre l'avis ministre de la
Défense anomalia disait que la nuit
avait été très dure pour les forces
ukrainiennes dans cette localité mais
elle a fermé que il continuait à
défendre leur position ce qui est
nouveau aujourd'hui ce matin c'est la
vie de l'Institut pour les études de la
guerre intime tant que basé à Washington
qui dit qu'il est probable que les
Russes ont effectivement pris le
contrôle de solidaire mais que cela de
leur avis ne faudrait pas forcément dire
que ils arriveraient facilement
maintenant à gagner une meilleure
position dans leur offensif sur la ville
voisine de batmout qui est beaucoup plus
grande merci beaucoup Gilly verkrag pour
toutes vos précisions merci à vous en